yeah for the last six months of the war
we've been really focused on the donbass
region almost um solely but of course um
herself as you said was one of the first
cities to fall so the question is why
was that a priority for russia so early
in the campaign there's two really main
reasons for that one of which is russia
if he wanted to take all of the coastal
region it would need to take odessa
hurston is a really important stepping
stone on the way to odessa but also in
2014 you remember the annexation of
crimea
at that time crimea was cut off from the
electricity grid from ukraine and also
cut off from the fresh water supplies
and that would explain why russia's so
keen on the nuclear facility at zaparica
access to electricity but also hersen
controls the canal ways that provide
fresh water into crimea so that's for
both of those um why zalensky why this
is also popped up in the news is
obviously the the
ukrainians have announced their
intention to mount some sort of
counter-offensive why now uh president
zolensky needs some good news bluntly
donbass has been heroic fighting but the
reality is that fighting has um they've
been seeding ground consistently there's
a weather window as winter approaches
where it'll be more difficult to conduct
warfare off the off the main roads and
basically they need some hope for the
ukrainians the challenge of course is by
announcing it
it means russia is preparing for it so
they are moving troops down from the
donbass region down towards hurston in
response what um zelensky has been doing
is blowing bridges along the dinipro
river to try and isolate russia from its
forces on the in herself and also
they've been bombing on crimea as well
um
part of the challenge though if you're
going to do a counter-offensive you need
overwhelming force or surprise
presidency has announced that he's going
to be doing that so there's no surprise
russian forces have been massing so it's
quite difficult to see how overwhelming
force will prevail the reality is we
don't know what the truth the matter is
but certainly the first stage of this
conflict are starting to unfold in front
of us yeah we'll keep an eye on the
situation in her son and
try to get to the truth of the matter
let's talk about reports um about the
russian president president putin and a
rift between him and his russian defense
minister talk to us about this story and
the significance of it well the russians
have not been performing well in this
conflict at all uh sergei has been the
defense minister for 10 years um you
often see him in full military attire
with lots of medals and general rank on
his shoulder he's never actually served
in the russian military at all uh
assumes the rank of general and of
course in peace time that probably works
fine when you've got the pressures of
armed conflicts and realities of war
it's pretty evident he's now described
as an ineffectual leader and putin is
now sidelining him going directly to the
operational commanders to find out how
things are going on the ground and with
the russian progress on the ground
stalled with the russian leadership
looking to be a bit more fragmented this
is a classic opportunity why ukraine is
taking full advantage on the ground at
the moment